Hi Dan. Dan's doing well.
It's good to be here. I left.
Austin was 75 degrees and
now we're a little bit,
even less than 70 opposites. It's
good. I brought scarves, I got hats,
all the things that
we have supplied him
with some Google swag.
So we are really excited to have you
here today. Derek, have to be here.
Thank you for having me.
So my name is Ashley [inaudible] and
today I'm just so excited to introduce all
of you to Darren k Roberts.
Darren has an amazing story.
Um,
it's not conventional in any means.
Darren is a Harvard Law
School Grad turned NFL coach,
yeah.
Turned bestselling author and now he is
a lecturer at the University of Texas at
Austin where he actually started a center
for sports leadership and innovation.
He's the founding director there.
Yes,
it's been fun and chase five little people
ages seven to seven months.
So
definitely. This is great. I'm glad
to be here. This is a break from home.
It's good. Good. So I will, we'll
talk about a lot of things today.
We'll talk about his book call an
audible. Um, congratulations on your book.
Amazon. It was one of their
number one new releases.
Sports illustrated said this is one of
the best sports business books of 2017.
Yeah, no big deal. Right? Yeah,
it's been fun. It was one of
those things, I don't know if,
if people are like me where you
have this Google doc and um,
it's, it's been living for
five to six years with ideas.
And that was where I was with this book.
I had been working on an introduction
for four years and I finally just woke up
one morning and told my wife, okay,
six days a week, two hours a day,
I'm going to write from
three 30 to five 30.
I'm gonna go to the same coffee shop,
turn off the Wifi and just go.
And she's like Godspeed.
And we did it. And yeah,
it would be really to hear it
is, it's like, it's actually
tangible. It's amazing.
And I have one too. It's
my own special copy. Oh,
did you read it before you go
to bed at night? They do. Well,
I've already read it and you know,
I'll read it again,
maybe after the stock and you can
buy more copies if you need to. Okay.
So I can't, I can't, you
know, go through you.
I got to go through and be better to
go through me. Yeah. Better take what?
I've got. Five college tuition, so
Gotcha. We have to support the hammer.
I understand. Um, so daring,
I mean you've done a lot,
but I also want to
mention in his free time,
Darrin also started in leads a
nonprofit football camp four.
Is it high school?
Cool. How's high school?
High school students?
So these are not blue chip athletes,
right? These are high school.
Try hard. I love Football
Darin types. Right? Um,
and we take them for a week,
40 high school students and in the
morning it's a yoga and meditation and,
and Ben, we play football for
about two and a half hours.
Then it's three hours of act prep.
And we built a curriculum where we
have taken the act math section and
translated it into football examples.
So geometry,
we teach geometry and Algebra or
using a football field as a grid. Um,
and then at night we have a series of
two workshops. So social media etiquette,
dress etiquette,
how to write thank you notes.
And it's been a wonderful program.
We've had 500 kids come
through in the last nine years.
So yeah,
it's really nice to know that you know,
you are giving back to commit to the
community and teaching practical skills,
right? Yes. The academic piece. But
also what, what should you wear,
how can you present yourself in a way
that is the best reflection of, of you
and one like the social media class.
Oh Geez.
So I will go through all of their,
so part of the application process is
they have to list their social media
handles.
And then we have a team of people who
we scrub all of their handles platforms
and take screenshots of the good,
the bad and the ugly. Oh Wow.
And they don't know what's coming.
And so on day four I of just walk up
and I'll have this dummy slide up about,
hey, how to make a speech.
And then slide two,
we'll be someone's post where it's
nothing but profanity and you know,
drinking a beer like, hey, who is this?
And everyone's embarrassed. Oh my gosh,
I can't believe you would do that.
So now hold on,
there are 2 billion people out
there on some form of social media,
why would you be embarrassed? Right. Um,
and so we start there and then kind of
work through how they can present a good
image online.
That's great. I think with, with
technology and with all social media,
it's so easy to just write
something or post something.
But if you were to actually sit like
in a stage and have the whole world,
I'm maybe you would say that maybe
your students or other folks wouldn't
actually.
Yeah.
And you know,
all the research right now is showing
that so much of what we do online is,
is subconscious.
So they're showing people tweets,
posts that they've liked or shared and
asking them if they recognize them.
And the rate's around 25% so
you're just scrolling, scrolling,
scrolling, scrolling, scrolling
like here, hard here or there.
And it becomes sort of stream of
consciousness. And so really for us,
we're trying to get the students to be
more intentional and deliberate about
their move. Right? So when
you hit the heart button,
we say for employers or other schools,
that is an endorsement.
So you need to think about, do I want
to co-sign on this message? Yeah.
And this is all in his free time,
right?
So in addition into the fourth
and one football camp, um,
Dan also leads a industry leading
podcasts and he's also the chief of the
Doughnut Council, which is calling
me my favorite part of this talk.
And we'll tell a little bit more about
that later.
Um,
and like I mentioned in some of the
comms that you might have seen before,
we will,
I've promised them if it's okay with you,
we will talk about Kevin Durant
and we will talk about doughnuts.
I love doughnuts. I can do that. Good. All
right. Done. Is that all right with y'all?
Okay, sounds good. So why don't
we start at the beginning. Okay.
You're a Texas born and raised.
And what did you, you know,
when you were a teenager kid, what
were your dreams? So fifth generation,
East Texan,
what stood out?
My Dad showed me this map of this Panola
county where he's from and it was a
census track from 1870 and there's a
plot of land that has 153 acres and the
name Bill Roberts and it's 1870 right?
So he points to the map,
he points to me and he says, this is
why you will never have any excuses.
I'm like, what the hell is he
talking about? Like I don't know.
And then I find out that my great great
grandfather finds a way to get 153 acres
in a county that sent troops to the
confederacy, right? Like how does,
how does it has a black man in
1870 like how do you do that?
And so my last book will be this,
I want to present three different
scenarios in a fictional way of like what
could have happened.
But that sort of set the stage for me of,
okay,
I got to pull the top off of my goals.
And so I want it to be the
governor of Texas by 40. Um,
I turned 40 in November,
so it took a wrong turn somewhere,
kind of push it out.
So everything was was um,
I want it to be the governor.
And so I thought that was
undergrad government, pre law,
law school practice somewhere run for
Congress, like very linear, you know,
if Aiden be, if he didn't see and uh,
now my life is just like, you know,
a sketchpad. Well, I love it. I think it's
just a different direction. But, okay,
so let's, let's talk about
law. So you want it to go to
law school. Why Law School?
Was it because you want it
to be governor and then was,
I know you kind of talked about Harvard,
there was something about that school
that really drew you there. Yeah,
Gregory Peck had a lot to
do with it. Right? So I,
if I think about the imagery that really
made me think about law school to kill
a mockingbird comes to
mind and seeing where this,
this powerful figure being able to
influence the community around him.
That was one image that stood out for me.
And then my dad bought a book of a,
it was a biography of Thurgood Marshall.
And just remember this image of him
standing on the steps of the Supreme Court
after Brown v Board in
thinking to myself like,
I want to be like that guy.
Um,
and so everything was
channeled towards law school.
And I'm at the University of Texas,
I'm student body president.
I had great grades. I'm like, I'm just
going to walk in to be easy, right? Easy,
right? They're going to like,
oh, we've been waiting for
you for the last 18 years.
Welcome, welcome, welcome. Finally.
Right? And get the letter back.
And it's the old wait list.
Right? So it's we like you,
we like some more people, a lot
more than you, and you're like,
how is this is like, you know, in the
event that all of them tell us no,
we may call you back, but if you have
better options, don't wait for us.
That's worse than a no. Yes it is. It is.
Because it's like your
clothes. I would, it's funny,
at the time I thought I wanted to know,
but in retrospect,
I think the list was probably better
because then there's like this little
glimmer of hope I could somehow
alter the situation some way.
Um,
but I wait list at four years in a row.
So Gwen Roberts and my mom's like, just
do something with your life. Right. Uh,
I worked on the hill,
I went to the Kennedy school and
then the fourth year I got in.
And was it everything
you imagined in more?
It was worse. It was worse. It was a hell
no. I, it was good,
but I like this. I was about to lie. I
was, I do like blatantly lied to myself.
I'm like, no, it was bad. Um,
it's an interesting place, right?
So you have 550 students come into a
class and everyone's so high strung.
You've got the folks who are
just fresh out of Undergrad.
So very going Berserk every
single second of the day.
The gunners on the front row hide worked
for a while. So I was kinda chill.
I had to make sure I got the Dunkin
donuts for going into class priorities,
priorities. But it was fun. I think I,
I really enjoy being challenged and I did
like the grind of like the one l first
year, you know, in the library. He kind of
steak a little bit. You're reading stuff,
you're falling asleep. I
liked that piece of it. Um,
but I knew there was something,
something else I should
probably be doing my life.
And so this talk is all about risks
and your story in itself is really
interesting, right? To pivot
so many different times.
And I'd like to know it was
your summer internship, right?
Your first summer
internship in law school.
Tell us about that
experience and how you felt.
So I worked at,
uh,
you know,
name, ampersand, name,
name, name, okay. In DC.
And
I remember the first day walking in,
working my way to my office
and recognizing the fact
that no one had smiled,
right. Receptionist, you
know, inserts first year,
associate insert, you know, throw
your partner. I thought, well, okay,
maybe it's just a rough time,
you know, that was the summer
and the highlight was the
highlight first day, this summer,
this first year associate comes in,
hey man, what are you doing for lunch?
I'm like, I don't have any plans. You're
going with me, right? This guy's not, hey,
welcoming. We'd go to lunch.
He's not talking to me. He's
like, on his blackberry,
it's 2006 was on a blackberry,
you know, and, and I'm like,
hey man, how's it going?
We're talking.
He's like,
I just love it when you summers get
here because we get our lunches, cops.
Oh my gosh. So you heated
it's recruiting, right?
He wanted you there,
not necessarily to talk to
you but to eat the lunch.
Yes. So then I thought, wow,
the highlight of this
grown man's life is a cot,
summer intern lunch,
like you're like visit.
So I remember going back
to law school thinking,
okay then there's probably something else.
And that's when my buddy the next year
calls me to go to work a football camp.
And we were both try
hard players with like,
there were no teams beating down
our door in high school saying come,
come play for us. And, but
he was a football coach,
a high school coach and he said, hey,
come to the South Carolina football camp.
So I get there and they need someone to
fill in for a coach who hadn't shown up
something they can play Texas
football and I wonder what's going on.
So I'll raise my hand. I'm
like, hell, where do you coach?
Like mount pleasant high
school. It's like, all right,
mount pleasant high school.
You have group six? Yes sir. I'm like,
what the hell is he talking about?
Groups six was 66th graders. Oh, okay.
None of whom had any athletic
talent whatsoever. Mom was,
had taken them to academy to get like
swooshes and they were protecting the
house and they were doing it and could
not back peddle like the length of this
stage.
Um,
and they had a coach who couldn't
coach best 72 hours of my life.
And I just,
there are these very brief moments in
football where socioeconomic status goes
out, the window was out of
town. You live religion,
like you're just trying to get
11 people on the same page.
And I recognize for me that became
a new form of public service.
So I started though the journey
to try to become a coach.
So I think many of us,
I'm sure you might agree,
oftentimes we have inklings to do things,
we see certain passions,
but what was it that got you from feeling
that you love this thing and shoving
it away as like,
okay,
that was a great 72 hour vacation and
then turning it into something tangible
and deciding you wanted to coach coach
football. So Renee Brown says,
she says emotions are data and I could
not get away from the feeling in my gut.
Like, even when I left the camp, I go
back to Cambridge. It was in my mind,
it was this an easy in my stomach.
And I've also just been up the belief,
my dad's a Baptist minister.
So if you walk into the Mount Olive
Baptist Church on a Sunday at 12,
24:00 PM, Kurt Roberts is
going to be standing up saying,
you don't know when you're going to die.
You better get right with Jesus. Right?
And I think hearing that for so long,
this just the delicate
nature of mortality,
like you don't know, we assume
so much. I've always thought,
let me try to pull these things and
I'm thinking about putting off into the
distance.
I can let me make them,
let me pull them into the present
tense because I don't know if I get to
retirement. Right? And people
are like, oh, just go practice.
And then you can do that as sort
of as a retirement job. I'm like,
who says I get to retirement?
Right? So, um, from that step
I went into excel, which if this
was 2018, I would've gotten a sheet.
Um,
and I went through every team in the
NFL and I found their address and every
coach on staff and I went through every
bio and tried to find some connection.
Are you from Texas and you're getting
a letter from me. Um, you know,
did you studied government Undergrad?
You're getting a letter for
me and I just wrote a letter,
multiple letters to every team in the NFL.
So that's part of this.
This is one of my favorite parts of this
book and I'm going to read a piece of
one of the letters. Dear coach and
you sounded exactly like this, right?
Yes, exactly. Your coach.
I am a third year student at Harvard law
school and I want to become a football
coach. After just three days of
working as a volunteer coach,
I realized that changing the
life trajectories of young
men can be fulfilled by
coaching a sport that I fell
in love first in high school.
I understand that you receive
countless letters each year,
but I promise I will work harder than
anybody else you are considering for this
position. And then you like went
down and you said, you know,
some other wonderful things and then
ended with please just consider me for any
entry level position you
may have available. Yes.
So what you sent this out to many,
many more.
Yes. In My, you know,
my last name wasn't Bella check and I
didn't have any buddies like I had no,
there was no end.
So for me I knew the only way that I
could break in would be to start at not
even the bottom, like below the
totem pole. And so what happened,
you sent this, I said this and I
got 31 rejection. So you know Bella,
check Tomlin, you name it,
going down the list, John Fox,
all of these teams are saying no. And
it gets to a point where, this is April,
this is two months before I'm graduating
and my classmates are going to the
Supreme Court and the White House and
insert banking and I bake here and I'm
just waiting on one.
Yes.
And I finally get a call one day from a
guy named herm Edwards who was at Kansas
City chiefs head coach. And he's
like, Hey, this is her Matt woods.
I need to talk to their Roberts. So
I think it's a prank. And I'm uh,
I'm about to say something that was,
wasn't not going to get this job.
I'm like, yes, sir. He said,
hey, I don't open my mail.
My secretary put this letter on my
desk. What's wrong with you? Right?
So I said, well, you know,
nothing that's been documented.
Uh, I worked this Cam, I'm telling me,
they were like, yeah, whatever. Okay,
here's the deal. He's like,
take out a pen and paper,
take off the training camp internally.
Yes,
no pay, right? It gets
better, no benefits.
And then he says 18 hour days.
So I'm going back to employment law.
I'm like,
this has gotta be some kind
of like 18 hours. He goes,
are you in?
And this three seconds sort of window.
And I knew I couldn't ask for
any clarifying information.
I said, yes, he's okay.
Graduate from law school. Get
here, hang the phone up. Right?
So I drove June the sixth from Cambridge,
Massachusetts to Kansas City,
Missouri and a 2002 Chevy Tahoe
that I still own because I'm cheap.
It's also why I'm a planet
fitness member. Yes. Um,
yes, yes. Um, and I was the grunt.
I was, I didn't sign a piece of
paper in six months like I was,
if you were to Google Darrin
Robert's Kansas city chiefs in 2007,
nothing would come up. I was, hey Darren,
offensive lineman would say, hey, we
need 40 barbecue sandwiches. Yes sir.
I'd go downtown, get the salmon. Just
bring it back. The defensive Lineman, hey,
we need two cases of dip
skull. Um, I go fine.
I go to seven. 11 is trying to like
as much dip as I could take it back.
I slept at Arrowhead for six months.
I got a twin blowup mattress and I
just wanted to be the first person,
the first face that herm Edwards saw
when he walked into the office four 30
every morning.
I was right there and I was the last face.
He saw him when he left at 11:00 PM.
And how,
how did you decide to give up law school?
And I'm sure you know that
life yeah. For, for this, yeah.
I had a professor, David Wilkins who
was a really great mentor of mine.
I'm talking with him about
the decision. He says, listen,
when you get your diploma, what you
won't find on it is an expiration date.
He said, I'm just going to take
a wild gamble here and say that
yeah,
when you leave the NFL there will
still be the legal problems going on.
So if you want to practice you
can, he said, let me ask you this.
How aware is this opportunity for you?
So like how many times will
NFL teams allow you to become
okay,
uh, coaching intern or train
to get better. And so for me,
I just thought that with every opportunity
that I get, I think to myself, okay,
one does it kind of flow in with my
purpose? And that was an easy check. Yep.
And then how rare is it? Like will this
come around or something like it soon?
And if the answer is no to that,
I'm taking it now.
And then just just adjust from there.
So tell us more about that first year.
Yeah, it good, bad. Yeah. Coaches
wouldn't talk to me for two weeks.
So I had all these coaches on staff who
were former NFL players and you know,
they paid their dues and they've got
this dude who hasn't coached or played in
college just around in the corner
in a Hoodie. And they're like,
what the hell? Who is this guy?
Like why did you bring them on?
But they sort of warmed up a little bit.
First game we play at Houston,
a part of my job is to make copies.
So I make up a copy of the plane
manifest for the flight and I see,
and Robert's seat 40 d oh there you go.
This is on a Thursday,
Friday chief of staff.
Hey, get all the manifest, throw away,
here's the actual manifest.
We had to make some changes.
40 d no,
Darin Roberts.
So someone in the organization
that you yanked my name,
they thought that I had
not paid my dues yet.
Pretty high up person in the
organization. Um, so I said screw it.
I bought a southwest flight from
Kansas City, Missouri, the hobby.
I land in Houston. I know where the hotel,
the team hotel is at Saturday night.
I'm the first person they seem to get
off her walks and he's like, dude,
this guy here's like, what are you
doing? He's like, were you on the fly?
I was like, no. I took a flight. Hey
listen, I don't want to be in the way.
I'm just going to sit in the back of
the room if you needed me. He's like,
we probably won't need you Darin,
but just stay out of the way.
They cool special teams coach.
He's like, Hey, what are you doing?
I was like, Hey, I took a flight.
I could use you tomorrow
because he had a lot.
We had a lot of new players and I need
to be able to find them when we go punt
or kickoff, so could you help me
wrangle players? I'm like, I could,
but don't have any credentials.
Can you kind of, yeah. He's like,
let me do something by midnight.
I had credentials by kickoff.
I'm on the sideline and I'm in.
And so I was on the flight
from that point forward.
But I think the point is like you really
have to barge your way in and like a
diplomatic way, right?
In a non creepy way.
Which in retrospect that probably was
creepy. So you had to be somewhat creepy,
but kind of find this balance.
I don't know.
I don't have like a nice
creepy factor, right? Yeah.
But I think it's so easy for us to send
emails and think that we've done the due
diligence.
Like the email is enough and you need
physical presence to separate yourself
from all the other folks who are
trying to get into this position.
Um,
and as you know,
today we want to talk about risk
taking and certainly your story.
Do you have tips for actionable things
that folks listening and Googlers here
you can take back to say, I have this
inkling I really liked to do this. Yes.
How can I get from there to
something that could be my lifestyle?
Yeah. So there's some really good research
that's shown that the Ikea effect.
So who shot that? Ikea, okay.
We've all done it, right?
You walk in and you sweat,
you smell those, you know,
kind of weird meatballs and you're
walking around and it's kind of odd.
It's weird. Anyway, they're
like halfway cooked and
so everything looks so
pristine and you're like, oh,
everything could go into my apartment.
Like I'll pick that desk.
You get the box and then you go home.
You realize you don't have any tools. Um,
you never assembled anything
since like third grade.
Now building the Mongolian the
volcano, if it doesn't go off, um,
and you build this thing and it's a
little wobbly and one of the drawers and
really pull out, right? But
it's yours and you built it.
We're finding that this ikea effect
and think about it as a sunk cost.
People think about the fact that they
dumped so much time and effort into one
course of action.
They use that experience and
that ownership to Ben talk
themselves out of taking
the risk.
Right?
Because I've worked at Google for eight
years and I started here and now I'm
there. I'm not going to take a
chance and now become a chef, right?
What we found is the way to get past
that is to expose yourself to rejection.
Okay?
So I'm going to challenge you to put
yourself in positions where people are
telling, you know, okay, here's
another technique or rejection resume.
She write this down, write this
down or tweeted, sing yourself or,
or t mail it to yourself or something.
We have many, many, many forms.
Um,
take your resume
and under education list all of the
schools that you didn't get into. Okay.
Work Experience. Every
job you did not get, okay,
go all the way down for
awards and distinctions,
all the awards and honors
that you didn't get.
Take it and then send it to
all of your friends. All right?
So I do some trainings with corporations
and I'll have the CEO or CFO do this
and then ask her to send it out. Right?
And first they don't want to do it. Yeah.
Okay.
And then they do it and they send it out
and it helps to humanize them and the
organization. So someone was like,
oh, I didn't get into Berkeley.
Either it's great. Or Oh, I
got turned down for the 30
for 30, you know, too. Right.
So I think building this comfort
level with rejection and was,
and getting the no helps because you will
document all of your big no's in life
and then realize I'm still
alive. Yeah. Like I'm, I'm okay.
And if I get a subsequent
know from taking a risk,
I'm going to survive because look at
all the things that I've been able to
withstand.
So really going through and catalog
and being very intentional about,
hey,
where at the time that I've gotten turned
down or didn't get the big thing that
I wanted and comparing that to,
I'm still in a good position.
Let me take that as confidence to go
ahead and take more risks. Okay. Um,
so in my class, my students,
they go on rejection challenges.
So to partners, so partners, you have to
go to Starbucks and ask for a free drink,
your partner videotapes you.
Okay.
And I had them do a pre
write up in a post right up.
And then we also take some
risks seeking scores. Right?
And they are so afraid. I mean, even
the partner, like we've got the footage,
can I am a Frazier? The partner
who's not even getting rejected,
it's like shaking back there.
Um,
we take all the footage and then we splice
it together and I show it to everyone
in the class. And that's usually a
pretty interesting day. But they go in,
they get the no on a Macchiato,
right?
You could hear them trembling in their
voice turn lane and then you have these
great papers being written when
they say it wasn't so bad, right?
Like
beforehand,
I thought this was going to be the worst
experience on the face of the planet.
I got the, no, it wasn't so bad.
I think I'm even willing to take
a bigger risk in the future.
So we're really doing a lot of research
around can we help to build your
rejection immunity by exposing
you write to new strains of,
of rejection. So, right. Yeah.
And so we, I mean, we're talking about
you as a lecture and as a teacher now,
right? Yeah. How did you, I mean
you were NFL coach, student view,
moved onto many different teams
and then you pivoted again, right?
You went from coaching in the NFL,
which was another one of your dreams.
Amazing work. And then how did
you decide, okay, time to pivot.
Let me take another risk.
Let me teach.
Yeah. So that's, that's all Dylan
Roberts. So I was in Cleveland.
Is anyone here from Cleveland
before I start making disparaging?
It's like it goes out to the world. We
have a card. Yeah, I know, I know, I know.
So this is a place called Cleveland.
Uh,
so we get to Cleveland in
2013 we went four and 12,
which as you'll know,
is not uncommon for the Cleveland browns.
And it was actually pretty damn good year.
Unfortunately,
the owner didn't agree with that
assessment. And we play at Pittsburgh,
we fly it back into Cleveland.
The last game of the season I get a text
from the owners assistant and it says,
aiding him staff meeting.
So we wake up and go into the office
and the owner walks in and he says, Hey,
really appreciate all
of your contributions.
You're all fired. All right, good luck.
It's like go home and I'm scrambling eggs.
And my son walks in and
he's tugging on my shirt.
I'm scrambling eggs thinking about like,
where is the next NFL city?
And he's tugging on my shirt. I'm
like, what's up man? You eat breakfast?
I'm like, yes. Scramble, scramble,
scramble, Tuck, Tuck. I'm like,
what dude? You mean eat breakfast?
Right? So I turned to my wife,
I said,
Hillary,
we are paying a lot of money for
this kid to go to a private school
and is it too late to get a refund or
cause I don't see that something's not
working.
Um,
my wife raised on a ranch in Kansas. She
said, well, let me ask you a question.
When was the last time you had
breakfast with Dylan? Right? Oh,
he's never seen you eat. Do you never see
me eat? And I'm like, Oh yeah, it was,
I could not pinpoint the time. Right. So
I have a breakdown.
Eggs are burning.
You've got alarms going off like man.
And just the irony for me was that
I had spent all of my time with other
people's sons and my own son didn't know
me, like did not. He was, he was
legitimately surprised to see me with
scrambled eggs and that was a problem.
So I decided to take a sabbatical.
Side note,
if you ever take a sabbatical be equation
is take the time you think and it's
five x. Okay. You're like, oh I
is going to be gone for a year.
And then I'll come back four years later,
I'm still on Sabbatical from coaching.
But it's been great. I went back to teach,
to teach at ut, some leadership classes,
the ray rice episode on the foals and I
take this proposal to our president for
us to create a center for sports
leadership and innovation, um,
to be more intentional around how
we teach athletes to become leaders,
to manage their finances.
And that was in 2014 and I present
the proposal and he's like, okay,
you're going to run it.
I said,
I'm on some sabbatical.
So kinda like here, but not,
he's like, no, you're running it.
And December,
2014 we launched.
So we've been at it for four years. It's
been, it's been very, very exciting.
I teach a class freshmen athletes at ut
and we started with Bernay Brown's work
around vulnerability and empathy,
migrate over into Angela Duckworth
and grit and Carol Dweck and mindset,
um, have our failure management sequence
where they go and do all these rejection
challenges and then end with a
leadership and financial management.
And how many students have
gone through this program?
So I've had 850 students I teach.
The great thing about the class,
I think Ashley,
is that we have half of the class
is comprised of student athletes,
half or nonathletes. Okay. So you
have these two worlds colliding,
you've got the receiver on the football
team sitting down with this computer,
you know, cs major. And one of the first
things I do on the first day of class,
I'll have the computer science major
come up and put her schedule down on the
board and I'll have the football
player come up and do the same.
And you'll see football player
5:00 AM workout, breakfast, shower,
you know, classes, lunch, practice tape,
get to bed at 10 11 the Coder,
the code has been up from like
11 to three working on code,
sleeves to 10 goes to class,
eat something around five and back the
coding. Right? And so I say, hey look,
the football player thinks, oh
we have it so tough. You know,
we have so much time that we're
putting into our craft. I said,
you've got folks who
are coders and training.
They are spending as much if
not more time than you are.
They just don't have 110,000 people
cheering them on on Saturdays.
So you're both putting a
lot of time into your craft.
Let's find ways to kind of bridge the
gap between student athletes and non
athletes. So it's been, it's been
fun. They keep me young. So this,
this pivot was more so unexpected,
but it's something that it seems
to be very fulfilling. Yeah.
I think my life has now been,
I'm trying to find ways to expand
the worldviews of athletes.
Football players for example, I tell
them you are mathematicians, right?
Like four quarterback to throw a ball,
45 yards to avoid two defenders over the
back shoulder of a person who's running
a four three 40 down the sideline with
the wind blowing 10 miles out of the
West. That kind of precision,
that is very complex math.
Take that and translate it
over into Algebra class. Right?
And they see these worlds as being two
separate spheres and everything that
we're doing is trying to break down
these barriers to say, you know,
when you give the speech at halftime
that helps your team to come back from a
deficit.
That's crisis management like that has
an application in the private sector.
Don't see it as, oh, I
was just, yeah, exactly.
This is what I would need to do outside
of that. Yeah, exactly. So let's,
let's bring those lessons
for in any sport really,
and translate those over into
life away from sports. Sure.
Um, can you talk about your story
about how Kevin Durant fits and all,
all of this?
Yeah. So Kevin Duran,
so Kevin Durant's, um,
spent one year at the University of
Texas was one and done and has such an
appreciation for that time.
Like, and when you talk to him,
he looks at that one year sort
of as the calm before the storm,
right. And was a phenom
out of Maryland. Um,
in 2015 he started thinking about how
he could have a better relationship with
the university.
And so
we're having conversations
with his agent and said, hey,
how about you come to campus,
make a speech? And he was like,
no, we'd rather do a one on
one conversation. And so we'd,
we did this talk and we just talked
through how much he loves mom,
which I think is incredible.
He talked about the fact that he thinks
that there's such a deficit of love and
people who are willing to be vulnerable
and that he's trying to help people
build a comfort level with
that. Um, and then he,
he talked about,
hey,
I want to find ways to be more supportive
of what we're doing on campus for our
athletes.
And so he's been a supporter.
Wrote a nice check to us.
Yeah. You weeks ago. Thank you.
Thank you. It was a nice check it. Yes.
$1 million that Kevin Durant donated to
the center that Darrin founded. So big.
Congratulations. Thank you. Appreciate it.
And if anyone wants the magic,
hey,
tell us whatever. We got it
all. I think there was a hand.
Yes. I got the little swipe,
a little stripe thing. Um,
so yeah, it's been great.
We've been able to really read a lot of
students and we're going to be a little
more ambitious now with some
of our offerings and we're
moving into that period
when we're scaling beyond
the University of Texas. So
amazing. Yeah. Well. Um, I
also want to let you know, um,
we'll have some time for questions. So
if you want to just line up at the mics,
um, have a few more things to ask, stare,
but please also feel comfortable
to ask him anything you want. Take,
take the risk, the risk,
the pledge, Darrin. Okay.
Now we talked about [inaudible] now our
other favorite topic. Donuts, right?
What is with you and Dona? Yeah, yeah.
And what is with this doughnut council.
So
I realize that I needed to be very
intentional about spending time with my
family and I think a lot of people say,
oh, I'll spend more time on that family.
And then that's on a Sunday and
then you get to Saturday. Oh,
I haven't spent any time with my family.
Right.
So I went into Google calendar and
we haven't even talked to rehab it,
we haven't actually
course just kind of up a temperature
level a little bit outside. Um,
so my family is color code is
orange and we have every Saturday,
seven 30,
I take the kids and we go to a
different donut shop in Austin.
And he said there were, how many? There
are? 38. Okay. Is that more than New York?
It's crazy. It's crazy. It's crazy.
It's like, and what's happened,
this has been going on for four years.
My aunt, my mom does embroidery,
so we've got tee shirts. I mean we
walk in and people are like, oh,
doughnut council. Hey,
copy a few, you know,
donuts but should have posts how you asked
for a free thing. That's right. Right.
Yeah. And now it's gotten to the
point to where my kids are becoming,
they're kind of becoming
snobs in the sense. Uh,
my daughter last week, we're
going to play, she goes, you know,
cinnamon rolls here a bit dry.
And which daughter is this?
How is Sydney Sydney's five?
I'm like sitting in your five,
just eat the damn thing. It's nice.
Like it's not as much as donut hole.
They have us just eat. Um, now I'm
spending a small mortgage. Right?
It started out, oh, half
a dozen donut holes here.
Have Fun people want,
you know,
bear claws and chocolate sprinkles.
So yes, our off three,
now we have five. Um,
and thank you long seven months.
And he's just trying to like get some
of the residue from the donut hole,
look at himself.
But it's also a great time for accurate
back with him around 11 so my wife can
just go and be childless for a while.
I mean,
she works for a nonprofit and also
helps with kids. And so she's,
it's good to kind of give her some space,
but we're at it for four years
and it's been, it's been fun.
So if anyone wants to donate to
the donut council, half $1 million,
half a million dollars, we'll go.
We'll go a hell of a long way. Yeah.
Maybe with the bear claws it'd be
like, yeah, yeah. With the brick house.
So now we're actually thinking,
my oldest wants to make a
pivot to breakfast tacos.
So you got to have new embroidery tee
shirts from grandma. We have bylaws.
Um,
I have veto authority.
I'm one of the permanent members and yeah,
self appointed.
I'm not sure I feel about, I mean we are
in Austin, Texas, right? So there's a,
there's a breakfast Taco in every corner.
Um,
but it kind of seems a little different.
Right? Different. It's not quite so,
yeah. So it's been a great way to
spend time with the kids and um,
it'll be fun because my, my
son was talking about, oh,
when I have kids I want
to do the same thing.
So it'll be neat to see
the grandkids doing that.
So I mean, the coolest part
for me about, you know,
hearing about the donut consultant,
why I wanted to talk about it today is
it's not just go eat doughnuts with dad.
It's, you talk about real
lessons. Can you share a little,
yeah.
So we talked through current events.
I usually pick a one current event and
then I'll put pick one character trait.
Right.
And so a couple of weeks ago was
gratitude and we talked about the value of
saying thank you and I'll have
them kind of think about, hey,
when was the last time you said thank you?
So Sydney,
you can tell Sydney
kind of runs the house.
Sidney said she got an extra slice of
pizza at school and she told the lady at
the cafeteria, thank you. Right. I
was like, well, how'd you get to act?
Just like it because oh well she knows
I really liked this cheese that they
don't normally have. And she gave me
an extra one. It's not dry. You know,
she's very particular about
our food. Um, and I say, well,
how do you think she fell? She fell.
She gave me a big smile. Right?
So we talk about how there are these
things called soft skills that people talk
about that's completely off their hard.
And these are the skills that will
get you fired. Hired governments,
fall, country's fall, right? Like
just truth and integrity. Um,
so they're very important in their
heart and we have to be very intentional
about, you know, talking about
them. So, um, yeah, they,
they're really, now they had their
own topics. Right now they're,
they're starting to bring him to like,
Hey,
can we talk about movies and how
we can get more time on the IPAD?
And I'm like, no, it doesn't really fit
in with the scalp veto power done. Right?
Yes. Yeah. It's not a soft skill is
fit. So it's been, it's been a blast.
So how do you,
I mean you are teaching students
and athletes how to take risks.
Yeah. Are you starting to teach
that to your children and if so,
how are you doing that?
Yes,
so I'm going to start this year actually
to kind of going through the rejection
resume. I'm gonna Start Broadcasting when
I want to get turned down from things.
So I picked,
I've been going through a two weeks
cycle with the Harvard business review,
pitching them as article about Superbowl
winning coaches and focus and how CEOs
can do the same thing and got so close.
And she finally was like, yeah, right.
What's like I took a
screenshot of the email.
I thought I'd just put us out on social
media without her information and say
got turned down by Harvard
Business Review. But you
know what? It just helps me.
I think the thing with rejection is
you can't, you can't take it personal,
but you have to make it personal in
the sense I have to dissect the entire
process. Did I give her enough time
that I really flesh out the proposal?
Could it have been more succinct?
And then use that for round number two.
So,
um,
with them we've been talking
about entrepreneurship
and our home and so my kid
said, hey, you know how you
stuff all those Christmas cards,
we want to start a business where people
will send their unstuffed cards to us.
Right.
I've got,
I've got like a legion right of hands
and we'll stop at for them and uh,
and mail them off.
I thought that's pretty good.
So my wife and I have talked about
having some sort of entrepreneurial theme
this year where we help them get
something off the ground. Yeah.
Well we can't wait to see what you do
next and what your kids, certainly Sydney.
Yes. Watch out for Sydney.
You think we have a question?
Hey there.
Um,
so I have a thought that I haven't fully
thought through yet and it just wanted
to see if maybe something you've thought
about, but how do you address like this,
um, you know, a person or you
know, whatever that's like coming,
you know,
acting like a person who is risk averse,
but perhaps their risk aversion comes
from a place of needing to be perfect.
Or, you know, when we talk about kids
and you know, I dunno when we grow up,
we talked about practice makes perfect.
Now I make a deliberate attempt
to tell him my daughter, like,
practice makes progress.
But I feel like a lot of us were raised
to think about being really perfect.
And I feel like when I think about
myself that I'm very risk averse.
But I wonder if a lot of my risk aversion
comes from this like psychology of
being raised to try to be perfect.
If that's something that you,
what was your name?
Catty.
First thing I want to steal
that practice makes progress.
So if you see it in another form
and now I'm just taking it from you,
it's yours.
Secondly,
so I was like Amazon last week and
one of their 14, I hope this is okay.
One of their 14 leadership
principles is a bias for action.
And I've adopted this massive
action thing for the year.
I deal with 300 freshmen a year.
And the helicopter parent phenomenon is
a very real thing where they land at the
University of Texas and it's gotta be
a foro highest honors President of this
club in the right dorm.
Like, you know, the,
the color of the bed
sheets have to be perfect.
Like everything has to be perfected.
So I'm constantly talking about them,
talking with him about imperfections and,
and also trying to get them to
favor action and to say, listen,
all you want is more data.
So if you wait to build this thing
until you have it all, would you,
will you think perfectly prepared?
You have,
you've kept herself from collecting the
data that would've gotten if you were
just throwing a Beta version
out there. Right. And so, um,
I think we do feel like,
and I think it's sort of this Instagram
culture of I need the right filter.
And the lighting and the angle
and then I'm going to post,
we've taken that approach and sort of
translated over into our professional
lives and I'm a big believer in
just throw something out there,
get the feedback, go for version two. Um,
because I think that's holding us back.
We have tenure projects that could
have been two year projects because we
haven't been willing to put something
into the marketplace and just let the
market speak for itself. So it's
a real thing. I think that um,
the more that we can just say this
doesn't have to be completed when I let go
that I want to take that data and a and
use it to make it better so they have a
good point.
Thank you.
Thanks for coming. Yeah, thank you.
I'm curious about your choice to get
into coaching versus something that might
have been like a more natural fit
with your Harvard law background,
like front office type work.
The goal was to do something really far
outside your wheelhouse or if you did
consider that and just that
wasn't where the passion.
Yeah. So and it's interesting
you say that your name again.
Todd is interesting you
say that because Todd,
I had the coaches on my staff say when
I first walked in the Kansas City,
oh you should go the GM track. Right? Like
[inaudible] you be a better, you know,
better suit of GM.
Um,
I liked the challenge of
starting something I play
in high school like I said,
but I didn't have any coaching knowledge.
Right.
And I liked the challenge of
having to learn a new code.
It's a language that was
more exciting for me.
Been sort of doing something
that resembled a bit of
what I had invested three
years and I say like we need to,
I'm constantly looking for
ways to stay in over my head.
And I thought that the GM
track made too much sense.
I really want to stretch my
mind in a different direction.
And I'll tell you what,
when you have, you have 25,
26 year old men who are 65,
240 pounds running four three,
eight forties, you know, flat
footed jumping 46 inches.
And you have to tell them the
routes to run on a certain play.
Like it takes a lot of courage to look,
look up at this guy and saying,
this is what you need to do.
Right.
And I knew that was going to stretch me
more than the office side of the job.
And the last point is,
what's ironic is it's
made me a better teacher.
Okay.
Dealing with athletes for seven
years has helped me, I think to be
a fairly good teacher in the
classroom. So, um, it was a thought,
but then I sort of dismissed it and
went for coaching. Yeah. Thanks Todd.
My name's Corey. Yeah, I
got it. And a question. Yes.
So if you're ever in Atlanta,
checkout sublime donuts. Oh,
best doughnuts in the city.
Oh, I would agree. We were, a few of us
were just there, you know, he didn't call.
Thanks. Look, you're getting me
in trouble. I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
Chin.
Kind of this idea of like when you were
talking about the illustration of the CS
students and the athlete and these kind
of two worlds combining with sports and
the outside world.
Yeah,
I feel like we're in a place where
there's very interesting things happening
with sports technology and those
kind of two fields together.
So I'm wondering if you've seen anything
happen on like ut campus or other
campuses or your program is working
with any programs to not only, um,
get the technology into the athlete's
hands to have them using it on the field
or in practice,
but also teaching them about
the technology so they can
get interested in it and
maybe change it for the
better to help future. Yeah.
Yes. So Cory, great first great
tip and then on the sublime.
And then great question.
So we're actually in the
fall we're unveiling a sports
entrepreneurship sequence
at the business school.
So we're going to have 20 athletes,
20 non athletes and they will
start it ideation all the way to,
you know,
putting the thing into the marketplace
a year long course and we'll bring in
sports entrepreneurs to expose them to,
you know,
this thing that we call entrepreneurship.
I think you're spot on because it's,
it's been relatively recent that people
have kind of looked around and said,
wait,
we can test.
Instead of waiting for
the data to come back,
we can just use the on the field data
from practice and from training camps to
inform the way that we build products.
Um,
and you actually have a couple of
athletic departments that are considering
building inhouse incubators.
Um,
so you see this with the 70 sixers for
example, um, where they're just say,
let's just bring this in house because
we have world class athletes to get good
feedback from,
let's use this setting as a space where
we can ideate and then test out new
concepts.
So I think this is really on the next
few years that this concept we're really,
really take off. Yeah. Thank
you Cory. I was good. Let's go.
Hi Darren.
Um,
my name is Veronica and I am
seeing in my field of expertise,
which is employment law, that at the
higher levels of corporate America,
especially, you know, we're dealing with
like c suite folks and the leaders in, um,
the companies,
uh,
that the soft skills that you alluded
to earlier directly contribute to the
breakdown of and meltdown
of workplace relationships.
So in your talks and your
trainings with those leaders,
what kind of response are you getting
from those leaders when you talk to them
about skills?
Like
vulnerability or,
yeah,
so at first they walk in and it's,
Hr has put this thing together and they've
got to go get real mushy for an hour,
right? So they own, they don't want
to be there. And then we really,
especially with vulnerability,
first I'll show them the research that
says for managers who score high on the
vulnerability scale, their teams produce
more, like all the things you care about,
revenue and shareholder.
All of those measures go up.
And it's counterintuitive. But the
reason is the team members say, Oh,
if she has the confidence to be
vulnerable and there are some limits,
right?
But to be vulnerable,
it creates this safe space and they
feel more comfortable and they actually
produce more and better
products and ideas and concepts.
So at first have to get them
to buy in that there's this,
there's this very real bottom line benefit
to being in using vulnerability and
empathy. And then I used that
hook to then say, hey listen,
it's also just good as a human right?
Like empathy,
the ability to take the
perspective of someone else.
If there is anything that's in short
supply right now and our country in the
world, like it's, it's to be
empathy, right? Because we're all,
we know the right answers. We know what
everyone should be doing. It's a black,
white, it's a very binary
world and a lot of us live in.
But to be able to stop and say,
I'm not from the same hometown,
we're not the same race or religion,
but I can see how she would arrive
at this feeling or conclusion.
I think that's, that's important.
It's an uphill battle though, I think,
especially in corporate America,
vulnerability, empathy or our Tufts sales.
But we're working,
let's take one last question and then
you can come and stare at a few more
afterwards.
My name's Zack. I'm curious, you
know, in the two pivots that happen,
they kind of came at natural points,
I would say as far as you graduated
and then maybe unnatural, but you know,
you were fired or let go. Um,
I'm curious, outside of that,
how often do you kind of
reevaluate where you are,
whether there's something else you could
be doing that would expand your impact
and, and moreover, you know, you've
done a bunch of different things.
You've coached,
you know,
a group of say 10 folks and your and
your 10 guys in your receiver group or
whatever. Um, and now you're
directing this big thing.
How do you compare those different
options and evaluate impact in all these
different,
yeah, man, Zach and just got
right to the heart of it.
That's the process. Like
right now, this is where I am.
So I'll talk about staying
in over your head. I am,
I'm constantly thinking now, like,
am I challenging myself enough? Yeah.
Um, I, my, if I get
comfortable, it gets a little,
I'm on edge and I felt like I may
be getting that point right. Um,
I'm also at the point where I have
determined for me that my life needs to
consist of writing,
speaking, and teaching.
And if I think about the commonality
between coaching and what I do in the
classroom, it's the teaching piece.
Yeah. That's the common thread.
So now that I've identified
that subset of what I need,
I'm going to filter any opportunity
that comes across my plate through those
three. It needs to go three for
three, you know, I'm going to be 40.
I can't go to for three. I need
a three for three set up. Um,
okay.
But I even don't know if I'm,
if I'm really challenging
myself enough right now.
Yeah. Um, so I'm actively thinking about
that and if you have some answers for me,
I will take that.
I'll pay you for them.
But I think it's a question that people
who want to be intentional about their
lives, they're constantly
asking that question. So
thank you. Thank you for that.
Thank you.
Well, Darren, thank you so much
for spending time with you, Ashley,
sharing your story. Um, I
have one quick question.
We really want really quick.
Superbowl Sunday.
Oh Lord Eagles by three
[inaudible].